[Music]
antivirus cyber warfare specialist Topol
well that sounds impressive just getting
in the right frame of mind for the job
hey let's order pizza like the hackers
on TV do I have some bad news about that
repeater no oh don't tell me we've
already stopped the North Korean virus I
was so into that I spoke to deputy chief
Rollins about your involvement in the
project now why would you do that
Rollins to test me never forgave me for
the mess I made at that key party yeah
he's not a fan his wife is though she
loves a mess no Rollins says he doesn't
want you within 30,000 miles of the
project 30,000 miles that's bigger than
the circumference of the earth
I bet he's exaggerating he doesn't think
your skill set is optimized for cyber
security that doesn't make any sense I'm
just trying to work up a catchphrase I'm
supposed to give you some busy work
while I crack the stacks in that case
how are you at collating this is
preposterous who is Rollins to tell me
what I can and cannot work on you know I
can count the number of enemies he's
killed on one hand and that hand doesn't
even have fingers get it yeah he's never
killed anyone do you know what we call
agents who've never killed anyone in
this business well-adjusted fingerless
hands men and you're such a big badass
damn straight I am if you had to count
all the foreign agents I've taken out
you'd need a lot of hands multiple hands
you remember Hands Across America no
that's not enough hands I can't disobey
deputy chief Rollins I'm offended my
kills count for nothing in this agency
anymore
once upon a time in this country the
number of people you'd murdered with
your own hands was a sign of your virtue
now it's all about how many spreadsheets
you manage or how many Twitter followers
you have have you heard of this is
twitter.com okay yesterday they should
called endless stream of comm
well you can reminisce about all the
people you've killed while you collate
files for me he used to be whenever
someone turned up dead I get a pat on
the back good old topo taking care of
business another enemy killed attaboy
top we'll keep them coming topple kill
kill kill
topple the unstoppable the murder
machine the death hold on I got an alert
sure I'll take a life without thinking
what do I care
oh my god basically if you ever hear of
someone dying under mysterious
circumstances that was me
deputy chief Rollins has been killed oh
well this is certainly awkward you know
I ought to go comfort his widow in her
time of need
[Music]